so equity
a poorly defined idea has taken over and
completely changed huge parts of the
United States banking air travel
you don't want equity in medicine do you
particularly in surgery well it's there
now the American College of Surgeons has
just declared itself to be a tool of
white supremacy suggesting that surgery
itself may be racist they say that
patients should have their surgeries
done by doctors from their racial group
as it was done during Jim Crow what
should we think of this well Dr Richard
bozhart is a surgeon he practices at
Bose heart and marsac Plastic Surgery
Associates and he has a really
thoughtful op-ed in the Wall Street
Journal
describing what's happening doctor thank
you for coming on uh tonight for being
willing to do this so why should we be
concerned by these ideas entering
medicine
Tucker thank you so much for having me
on the show I'm sitting here and I'm a
little bit in disbelief that I'm even
here
don't take this incorrectly or wrongly
but I almost wish I didn't have to be
well I agree I am a plastic surgeon once
also board certified by the American
Board of general surgery and I've been
practicing for over 33 years
last year I was banned for life from
access to members of the American
College of Surgeons on their online
discussion forums
the ACs for people that don't know is
the largest organization and also the
oldest in the world representing
surgeons and also surgical patients the
mission of the ACs which was written
into their initial mission statement to
serve all with skill and Trust has since
been changed
there was supposed to be promoting
excellence in surgery and supporting
surgeons and their patients
unfortunately this is no longer true
my band occurred because
two years ago
I noticed that there was a direction of
the ACs to try to jump onto this
systemic racism bandwagon that seems to
be very popular these days the ACs
leadership went to war
against itself it declared the ACs the
American College of Surgeons to be
structurally racist it also went on to
say that surgeons are racists and even
the practice of surgery is racist
what this did is it produced a type of
messaging
that now states that as you clearly put
it's best if patients are treated by
surgeons of their own race
Tucker let me ask you a question
if you are looking for a surgeon for
yourself and a loved one or a loved one
what are you looking for in a surgeon
skill
yeah
skill absolutely
what about trust
of course I would say that after skill
probably the single most important thing
that goes into providing good medicine
is trust yes
a patient has to trust that a surgeon is
not only competent and skilled but also
has their best interests at heart and
will do the best for them a surgeon on
the other hand has to also trust the
patient
that they will understand that the
surgeon is doing his or her best
yes
and
Dr boschart I wish we had more time I
hope you will come back for a much
longer conversation because I think this
matters more than almost anything else
and I appreciate your bravery coming on
tonight subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight